[Music]
on today's show we talked to a mom who
wants some tips on how she can support
her son who's a freshman
in college and living in a residence
hall we talked to a husband whose
wife and him have different sleeping
schedules and they want to know how they
can unite
and we talk to a remarkable mom and wife
who has a great husband but he just
doesn't take care of himself
and she's scared she's gonna lose him
also we talk about how to take bricks
out of your backpack in a special
teaching segment
stay tuned
hey what is up good morning good
afternoon
good evening good night i don't know
where you are i don't even know what
time it is
but i hope you're doing well hope things
are going well in your life
hope people around you are using their
head hope you're not watching too much
news because
i know the other things i just said that
i hope things are going well would not
be going well
this is the dr john dolone's show we're
so glad you're here i'm glad you're here
on this show we talked to real people
about real things going on
in their real lives right not the
imaginary internet worlds not the
imaginary
news worlds or netflix worlds but real
things going on in real people's lives
mental health challenges relationship
all of it whatever is happening
i love talking to folks walking
alongside people i like figuring it out
for myself because i'm
a dad i'm a husband too i'm trying to
figure out what to do next as well
um so whatever's going on in your life
give me a shout at
six nine 1-844-693 thirty two ninety one
that's one eight four
four six nine three thirty two
ninety one or you can go to
johndelony.com
show fill out the form and it goes into
i don't know the internets and it does
some loops and somersaults and then it
goes to our good friend kelly
and then she makes the decision on
whether you get on the show or not
she runs everything all of the things
weather
kelly texas was a rough a couple of
weeks
kelly kelly
how your car's driving this morning
kelly
i got a flat tire kelly all of it
everything
and the good things in your life man my
wife is loving me more
kelly all of it it's kelly i look really
good in these bands today
kelly all of it is because of kelly go
to john delany.com
show she will decide all things
including who gets in and on the show
and we're gonna get right to the phones
today we got a action-packed adventure
show
we are going to go back to a geek
segment here not quite a geek segment
but we're gonna
get some emails that are keep coming in
coming in so we're gonna address some of
these bigger picture things but let's
first go to nikki in salt lake city
utah nikki what's going on
not much it's pretty early here i can't
even
imagine you sound like it is 4 30 in the
morning and it might be in salt lake
city
um almost no just kidding getting up and
getting ready um well thanks for joining
us so early
on your side of of the earth how's it
going thank you
good i am a mom of six
um my oldest son is a freshman in
college this year
all right because of some yeah exciting
um because of some health concerns that
he's had and also some
dumb decisions that he's made he's down
to his last hundred dollars
oh um in the bank yeah and so i know
he's gonna need
help but i wanna know how i can go about
helping him in a way that will cause him
to be more
independent in the future gosh
so this is a big shock to parents
everywhere that your freshman
in college made some potentially dumb
decisions so you're out on an island
there by yourself on this with nikki and
i'm sorry
so joining the ranks of every parent
who's ever lived in the history of
earth um your 18 year old did some dumb
things
talk me through that what are some of
the challenges he's experiencing
well his senior year of high school was
pretty rough
he was um he was signed up for five ap
classes had his you know a job after
school he knew that he would have to
save up for
his living expenses and that we would
pay tuition
um but then he he started having
seizures
and we um we went to a million doctors
uh they ruled out all of the
life-threatening scary things and they
said they were kind of related to stress
i'll just say stress related yeah okay
yeah
and it's it's common in um
people who have been victims of sexual
abuse or you know war vets to have
so much stress that their body reacts
that way right um a few months later
he was also diagnosed with type 1
diabetes
so he he had like the worst senior year
ever
and working through the summer was
difficult for him and i think one of the
ways he copes
is that he plays video games so you know
i'll i'll check on his accounts every
once in a while and go oh my gosh
you've got 150 why did you spend more
money on video games
right so i don't want to give him a
large sum of money
because i think he would spend it on
video games
and you know i i have this internal
debate like
oh it's so hard they're quarantined at
college they're not in classes talking
to people but on the other
hand you know i don't want him to waste
all of his time online gaming sure
you know instead of actually learning
something at school
yeah so how are his his grades
um he's passing they're they're kind of
mediocre
um not representative of a guy who
was academically successful enough to be
in five ap classes just
a calendar a year ago right yeah
well he's he's studying computer science
and animation so
art classes and computer science classes
he will
hyper focus on those he loves those
subjects and then it's like oh
i may not pass writing i may not pass
history so
i mean i'm okay with him getting c's in
the classes that he doesn't want to
and and you know when i talk to him he
says mom i can tell
i need a better work ethic i need to do
well so i can get into this program that
i want to get into
um does he take advantage of the
resources
at school at the university
um you mean like the disability
resources or
even even beyond that every college
on earth has staff that
are will teach you how to
learn new studies study skills learn new
study strategies
there's a counseling center there are
health clinics there are yeah there is
disability support resources there's all
sorts of resources
there's a residence hall director who
will is
their job is to create community even in
this wacky messy time and i've been on
the phone with a couple of them this
past week even
the former colleagues that are just
calling me to ask me for for
professional advice
um there's so many resources at the
college university level
and what i find often is especially
unplug disconnected
freshman boys right freshman young men
will get disconnected if they don't have
the tool the relationship tools they
don't
understand how hard relationships can be
that you got to work at them
and then really video games become
they become alcohol they become they
become
weed they become a way to
disconnect they become a way to just
numb out right it just makes things i
can just kind of
tune out right um it doesn't come with
the same
social stigma or the same um you know
legality issues but it's the same thing
it's just a numbing out
i'm just i'm stressed i'm completely by
myself here and so i'm unplugging a
little bit
so does he not take advantage of any of
those resources at all
so i i do know that they have like um
free mental health
services for the kids and hey by the way
you like how we do that um colleges
they'll charge you a hundred thousand
dollars and then they'll be like but we
got free counseling right so
this is just a call to anyone in america
if you want to send me 50 000
i will give you all the free counseling
you would like all day long
um but yes so they've got counseling
services study skills services
um academic support services um
does he take advantage of that stuff i
encouraged him to get on the list for
some mental health
counseling um and there's such a long
list because of kovid i
he they put him on the waitlist and i
don't think he's gotten in and it's
middle of second semester okay so that's
kind of a bust
um i i have encouraged him to go to the
disability office and and i said you
know if you need more time for homework
they could work something out
because but here's the thing it doesn't
sound like he needs more time for
homework
it sounds like he needs some skills
and i'm not going to beat him up because
i i don't know what his
i obviously you said he's been through a
lot right but he's got to
acknowledge the fact that i need some
more skills not just say it out loud man
i really have a bad work ethic
and so i'm gonna go buy another game
because i know i have a deficiency
and instead of dealing with that
deficiency that challenge
i'm going to numb out right i'm going to
check out
so yeah saying i need to do these things
and then going to get the help you need
is important so two things you've told
me one
i would lean heavily on the school
heavily on the school and i'm telling
you that as somebody who over the last
15 years parents
all over the country have leaned heavily
on me i need more
counseling resources we need to do my
kid
is paying the same as everybody else
they haven't been able to get into a
counselor
at my last university um that i worked
at with belmont university
their counseling center did some such
extraordinary
turn of events such extraordinary shifts
and changes in how they provided care
for people
it was it was revolutionary and they
began to to serve a
much wider group of students because
they had to do things differently and
they rose to that challenge so i tell
you as a parent
don't just accept well it's been seven
months but they can't get in i want you
to get on the phone there because you're
paying that bill
i want your son to get on the phone and
say hey this isn't good enough that i'm
just been on a wait list for this long
the second thing is i would not
continually fund
i hate to say misbehavior i would not um
continue to fund
a continued behavior set right so if my
son
showed me i'm gonna go get the help i
need i'm gonna go get these additional
skills
then i'll be more likely to support him
but right now he is choosing to not do
the things that are gonna help him be
well
in light of the challenges he's
experiencing does that make sense
and so i know as mom the hard part is
you know how hard his
his health issues have been you know how
hard
his stress has been so much that his
body said hey
we're we're we're fritzin out here right
the body started shutting down
because of the stress and so as a mom
you want to
not at feel like you're adding more
stress by giving him some boundaries
what i'll tell you is the thing he needs
more than anything else is somebody in
his corner
and somebody who loves him enough to set
boundaries and have expectations
right he's not broken he does have some
challenges he's gonna have to learn some
new tools for but he's not broken
okay and so i think it's worth
noting letting him know hey we love you
we're going to start holding you to a
high standard you can't buy video games
anymore we're going to cut you off
financially i'm just not going to do
that
and you know we know we all know
locking yourself in your room and just
playing video games is not going to help
you've got to get out and do
learn some new skills if this isn't the
season for him to be in college
that's okay that is super okay
um i one of the challenges i always
worked with students especially high
achieving students like he sounds like
he was
is they have a track and if they get off
that track everything in their life
spins out if i don't go to school this
semester and then the next next or next
semester
it feels like they're going to be 21 and
then they're not going to be able to
fill in the blank
man that semester means nothing in the
long term nobody
knows or cares when you're 25 right and
so it may be if he's not being
successful if he's in five ap classes
he's
could do some results through his
freshman and sophomore year of college
he should be able to make straight a's
maybe a b or two here without trying at
all um that tells me if he's getting c's
that means he's not turning work in that
means he's not even opening a book
in some of those other classes he's not
even writing a i mean he's doing
below the bare minimum for somebody who
has that sort of
intellectual firepower right um when you
when you hear i hear in your voice when
you hear me telling you hey you're gonna
have to put the boundaries back on and
ratchet it back up on him
how does that make you feel it sounds
like you don't like that that sound of
that
i i try and analyze every
situation well what are the pros of
helping what are the cons of health and
so
like i can i can see the pain i can see
the
i don't know like the this horrible
situation that these college kids were
in
you know
don't go outside don't interact with
anybody don't stay no social life
and so that that's hard for me to say
you know here's
there's this really crappy hand yeah and
i'm out yeah
well no it's not it's not i'm out in
fact it's i'm more in
i am more in but i'm more in
with these these particular boundaries
right or
you're exactly right is there any sense
in having your kid go live
in a 14 by 14 box with three other
people
hey let's just call it we're gonna do a
community college for a year you're
gonna live at the house at least in our
house you can run around and see other
people
they're your brothers and sisters but
you can see other people and then once
this thing opens back up then we'll all
roll back into school
but you're right these kids are in a
nightmare right now it's ridiculous so
what i'm don't hear me say
roll out what i or just let him off the
hook let him go
i'm saying the opposite i want you to
get more plugged in with him
with boundaries if he's if he's going to
these
resource um if he's checking in with
this the student support services if
he's learning new skills
if he is limiting video gameplay to 30
minutes a day
and the other ones he's going to read do
homework study reach out and learn some
new skills
then that's great these kids are so
bored
so stressed so unplugged so disconnected
i don't blame them for playing video
game what else can they do they can't go
to the gym they can't go outside and
play frisbee they can't
go play baseball they can't no
intramurals they can do nothing right
and so i'm i'm i'm man i'm i'm asking
the whole big question why are they even
in school right now that's their that's
their life
some schools have figured it out and are
doing some pretty remarkable things some
are not
but at the end of the day what you don't
want is it a him to go to school
on top of all the stress he had last
year on top of his health issues
an important part of type one glycemic
response is sleep
going to bed getting good sleep
every single night of the week video
games in a room doesn't help with that
they stay up all night and do that i
know that
and so how can he get plugged back in
and take care of himself from the bottom
up
that may be coming home that may be you
saying i'm not going to give you any
more money to buy any more video games
you can't keep funding that is what i'm
saying
but it may also mean you're going to
have to have a hard conversation to him
i love you i love you i love you
this isn't working because i don't want
you to get into you have straight seas
one or two a's
and then he feel like he failed so
that's a different kind of stress on top
of the stress he's already got
partridge in a pear tree right on and on
and on so
these kids are in a hard situation that
doesn't mean that they don't have
boundaries they're in a
completely disconnected lonely that
doesn't mean they don't have to do the
things that keep them well
and moms and dads that doesn't mean you
just keep putting money in the count
so they can keep doing things whether
it's video games whether it's alcohol
whether it's buying weed whether it's
whatever it is
they don't just get a free pass because
things are hard right now they need to
do other things
right not just keep plugging along
plugging along plugging along i love the
fact nicki that you love your son that
makes my heart feel good and i
i i've just worked with i can't even
tell you how many kids just like him
who've got so many struggles out of
their senior year it's an
it's a it's a hard thing but once you
recognize it then you got to go make
other decisions
it's not going to look like you and i
when we went to college our freshman
year we got to own that and then move on
so
thank you so much i want you to have
that hard conversation or have him how
about this
have him call me i'd love to have him on
the show and talk through what the last
year has been nikki
i'd love to talk through some strategies
for him because i've talked to students
like him for
for the last 15 16 17 years and then
maybe i can give him some tools maybe i
can say things to him in a way that he
can't hear from his mom or from his dad
or from his residence hall director
that's going to help him make some some
broader heavier life decision changes so
thank you so much for that call nikki
let's go to kevin in provo
utah right down the street kevin what's
going on man
hey how much john how you doing good man
good good good how's provo
oh it's great you know weather is good
very cool
well brother what's going on how can i
help hey so
my wife and i are having a communication
issue and uh
we've been pretty good at hard
conversations in the past but uh
we're stuck on one and i think this will
turn into kind of a broader conversation
about
um you know having hard conversations
and stuff so but the example that we've
been
dealing with and struggling with lately
is kind of a nighttime routine
um we're both really really busy through
the day i
i have uh uh i'm a supervisor at work
and i got a lot on my plate and she's
got
three little kids to deal with our kids
are
amazing and she's you know a full-time
mom with them
and uh our night time routine's a little
wonky like uh i'm an early bird i need
to get up early
so i would like to get to bed early um
but she is a night owl and she craves a
lot of
uh connection once you know all the kids
are in bed and i
crave that connection too like i need to
we need to connect with each other and
um 2020 was um
it was a hard year for a lot of people
but for us we were
able to connect with each other more
yeah and it was what was one of the best
years of my life actually because we
finally got on the same page with a lot
of things very cool
and and so talking at night and
we have some great alone time together
we'll watch a tv show and then we'll
just
you know talk and have conversations put
down the distractions we have good
conversations but then
um the time creeps by and
it gets to be you know 11 11 30 midnight
and i'm looking at the clock and i'm
like i gotta get up early
and i you know
have stepped on a lot of landlines in
the past couple weeks where i
will say all right well you know thanks
for talking i love you
and i you know i got to get to bed and
it just really hurts her feelings
because
she craves kind of like quantity of time
she wants a lot of time to talk so
anyway how how do you what do you
recommend how do you um
what advice you have for couples who
just um i i crave that connection that
really really helps
me it's helped a lot over the last year
but like when
the physical meets you got to go to bed
right exactly
yeah so my my house is exactly
different my me and my wife's schedules
are exactly different
and i'll tell you how we worked through
it first
was she my wife needs nine or ten hours
of sleep
and i used to think that was ridiculous
and silly and that she was being
dramatic
dude i i have a different human living
in my house when she gets seven hours of
sleep versus nine
it's a different human right
and i would get home from work we had
the exact opposite when the kids
um were in bed she wanted to
crawl into bed and be in bed by 8 30.
there's no reason on earth to be awake
after 9 30.
what in the world is happening after 9
30. and i'm the opposite i was
working i work i have hard conversations
with people all day my head's spinning
all day
i get home and i just want to veg out i
want to kind of almost take a little
rest time between
six and eight six and nine and then we
can get up and like
then the rest of the evenings hours
right an evening being nine to about
midnight right
and um so ultimately i had to realize
two things number one
nobody in our house is help healthy or
whole
if they're not getting the sleep they
need so that
became priority number one okay so what
that what did that mean that mean i had
to adjust me
she also had could adjust up another 30
minutes or another hour
okay so we've settled ish on 9 30
or 10 and what i learned with me is that
what i
thought was i needed with was craving
with connection time and just hangout
time
i needed to be asleep man i was
exhausted i was
chronically exhausted all the time and
i moved from one thing to another thing
to another thing trying to just
prop myself up to stay awake stay awake
stay awake because then i was like i
finally get this time
man that ended up being a disaster so
i've learned over the last five to seven
years
um man if i'm up past 9 30 or 10 now
i am i hate everything i hate everything
right i love going to bed now and so
it took me changing my
thoughts it took me how about this
here's a way to practice it
when you get home and you help with
bedtime do you help with the bedtime
routine
yeah i do good deal that's awesome man
so you help with the bedtime routine
structure that after bedtime
structure that time sometimes it feels
like this
this amorphous just quote unquote time
together
you sit down and structure hey what are
you looking for in this time
right what do you need from me and when
i finally got to where my wife
i just want to talk to another grown-up
adult human being that i can be open
with and vulnerable with
i need physical touch i want to just
watch a show and laugh
right and so it kept this
amorphous time my wife would ask me what
do you need man and then finally i
realized i need to go to bed
i need to go to bed so structure that
time together
give each other 30 to 60 days ask your
wife hey can we
go to bed at 10 30 right we're going to
have the kids
oh by the way here's another quick
question when your kids go to bed when
they go to sleep
so we've gotten a lot better
before it was like just whenever but now
we literally start bedtime at seven
and try and have them in bed by eight
and it's
that's been so much better but now we
have we literally we have so much time
after eight that we're just
continuously you know having
conversations and
and one thing i will say it is
uh like i said it's been helpful because
like
i had a really bad habit and
talking to her and talking things
through with her really helped me kick
that habit and so like
talking with her really really has been
so helpful and so like
it's hard for me to imagine like not
having that conversation but then
it always hits that late hour and it's
like dang i i'm exhausted like i have a
an hour-long commute uh you know and i'm
like
worried i'm going to fall asleep on the
road and drink lots of soda i don't
really want to be drinking yeah i don't
do that
so do don't don't apologize for the
sleep you need okay
yeah and everyone does that differently
i have to have eight hours of sleep or
i'm useless my wife has to have ten
that means we're gonna have a gap there
okay it just does it just means we're
gonna have a gap or she's gotta have
nine
um and i've gotta be okay with that
she's gotta be okay that we both got to
act like adults
and that also means that we've got to
have the time that we do have has to be
focused i can't be
talking to her and just nodding while
i'm scrolling right and if we're going
to watch a show we do
we have show night on wednesday that's
our that's i shoot
my shows on monday tuesday wednesday
generally and um
so i'm tired i'm super tired wednesday
nights that's when we all
we laugh and we put on a silly show and
watch some chili show right
um i would recommend putting in it's
gonna sound so ridiculous like you're
ten again
i would recommend putting in a bedtime
at ten o'clock the lights go out
and i'm gonna ask you wife that we turn
the lights off and that you will
stay in bed that you will turn the
lights off too at 10 or if you need to
read you know for another 15-20 minutes
let's do that for 30 days can we just
commit to that together
and then you those two hours that are
just y'alls are just
lasered in on each other whatever that
means whatever that looks like for y'all
if that's intimate time if that's just
chit chatting time
if that is doing budget time together
checking on calendars
those two hours are just rich gold
between the two of you
but then at 10 the lights are going to
go out and letting her know hey
i not in this uncertain like i've got a
lot of things on my plate when you
approach it that way
her immediate response is well i got a
lot of crap on my plate too dude
so don't approach it with here's how
hard this burden is approach it the
other way which is
i need this much sleep and i need this
much connection time with you
so here's how we can do both of them
kids are in bed by eight o'clock
then we got two solid hours of just one
another and then at 10 o'clock i gotta
turn the lights
out and just try it my guess is you will
modulate up half an hour or down half an
hour
but if she's anything like me i just
wanted the knight to keep going and keep
going and keep going
and dude now i am 9 30 nerd
deluxe i had just never done it before
right
so practice that time it with
intentionality
let her know not how busy you are let
her know i've got to have this much
sleep
i've just got to and i want to be fully
present when i'm here i want to do my
best job at work but i really want to
help with the kids i really want to love
these children well and i really want to
love you well as you said
as we've done this year that's so
awesome that 2020 has been a good
connection year for you
i'm hearing that all over the country
couples who just decided to
reimagine what their world was going to
be like but hey
for 30 days this this idiot on the radio
said let's try 30.
let's try turn the lights off at 10
o'clock let's just try it and don't get
out of bed because i used to just jump
up she turned the lights off at 9 30
10 then i'd go hang out and watch tv
until midnight and then i just turned
into this
drippy exhausted sloppy just mess
just and then i'd get up and be late to
work but just don't do that
say for 30 days to stay in bed until 10.
let's try it
let's just try it you can even hold
hands as you all go to sleep look how
romantic that was
friday morning romance here on the john
delaney show
um let me know how that goes call me
back in 30 days or have her call me
y'all both call me back and i want to
see
how the romance is deepening in kevin's
house
because we're all going to bed at the
same time all right so
i get this email with a lot of
regularity
and so i wanted to took a minute to
write some notes out on this
here's an example of an email here's one
from tracy it says i regularly
you regularly tell listeners to put down
their cinder blocks that they're
carrying around in their backpack
my question on behalf of all listeners
thank you tracy for acting on behalf of
everyone
is how practically do we do that what
tips do you have for letting go i know
that my cinder blocks
are but i'm struggling to put them down
and not carry them around as a result
they continue to intrude in my mental
health i'll tell you this
they intrude on more things in your
mental health they intrude on your
relationships they intrude on your
physical health they intrude on your
spiritual they intrude on everything
your financial health on everything
right
so here's here's a couple of things um
tips i wrote down four or five
things here um and you can get out some
notes and write these down
the first thing when you're thinking
about putting on your bricks and when i
talk about bricks i'm talking about what
are these things that you carry around
with you
all of the time since you were a kid
some of them
come over time right some of them are
recent
right but these bricks are childhood
traumas
the stories you're born into right your
family stories this is just the way we
are
systemic issues right racism poverty
those kind of stories that you were just
born into because of whatever culture
you're in
somebody hurt you right the voices that
you allow in your head or that you the
way you talk to yourself these are
bricks that we carry on this all day
right this idea that i cheated once
then i put that in my backpack because
i'm a cheater right it becomes my
identity
right so the number one thing when
you're thinking about how do i
walk through life lighter right how to
put these bricks down is
decide you don't want to carry them
anymore
and that sounds ridiculous of course i
don't want to be a an abuse victim
survivor
anymore of course i don't want my
parents to have talked about me the way
they did when i was a kid of course of
course fill in the blank
but here's the thing when you carry
stuff around for so long it becomes part
of you
right if you've ever been on a boat all
day and you get off the boat and the
ground still feels wobbly
that's how it feels when you put stuff
down our bodies crave that equilibrium
and in fact not only our bodies the
people around us
if you see folks who lose a lot of
weight it often
really affects their relationships
because
people in their world are used to
helping them out always listening to
them their self-defeatist talk or listen
you know that just that feeling of
frustration
people lose a lot of weight they start
exercising they start eating right their
self-confidence
rises right they start walking a little
bit taller
they start speaking with a little more
self-assurance the people around them
want to put that back where it goes
right you want to put that back where it
goes right
you see yo-yo dieters you see folks who
go in and out of counseling over 5 10 15
20 years
so you've got to decide i want to put
these bricks
down right i was hurt as a kid
and i'm gonna heal and move on right yes
my mom said stupid things
yes there are massive systemic
injustices yes
somebody died and they were not supposed
to they were supposed to be with me
till the end right or i've
learned addictive behaviors that help
protect me from pain or from
disconnection
or from messed up relationships but
these addictions now have side effects
that are causing me new traumas which
are causing me to have to withdraw more
over and over and over or i no longer
want my identity be
from the worst things that ever happened
to me i don't want my identity to be the
worst thing i ever did
right i stepped out on my husband so i'm
a cheater forever
right i want to put that brick down how
do i heal and move on for that okay so
number two
you gotta name them and you gotta be
specific and honest
right often trauma these things swirl
around in this giant soup in our head
right and we say things like
i hate myself i hate church i hate my
family or i hate filling the blank
these type of blanket statements are a
waste of your breath because they're
just
reductive they don't they don't help
anything right you have to be specific
and be honest what about your parents
or family or old boyfriend or whatever
it is
what about it do you hate what about
them hurt you right here's church i hear
this a lot i hate church because of the
trauma i experienced as a kid cool
lots of churches have hurt lots and lots
and lots and lots of people
right but if you just walk through life
saying i hate church
then it may cause your alarms to go off
when you're on big groups
when you're around communities when
you're around a collective group of
people who all have a singular mission
to help other people
right and those three things aren't
necessarily bad
but if you're walking through life like
i just hate church then you're going to
start watching your alarm systems are
going to go off for various things
that look like church so you've got to
parse it out and say
it could be i didn't hate church i hated
that guy
that hurt me right or there are a couple
of
really outspoken mean idiotic families
at the church i went to
or there was a particular minister
that was not a good human being right
what is it be specific just because
you're dead oh and here's here's uh be
specific and be honest right
so here's where the honesty comes in
just because your dad yelled at you
or your mom told you things that are
still lodged in your brain
doesn't necessarily mean they were evil
they might have been but it could have
been that they just didn't have the
right tools in their toolkit
so part of being honest is being able to
slowly unwind that
i have some bricks in my backpack that
are from things kids told me
or young people did to me when i was a
young person right
old girlfriends guys i ran around with
um
guys i lived with right things they did
things they said that hurt me that
altered the way i live my life or saw
myself or still see myself right but
here's the thing
they were kids they were 20
right i don't hold it against them why
would i waste my adult energy hating
children
right but i do have to process the hurt
i still do have to process the pain i
have to process those voices right so
i've got to be honest on both sides of
this thing
right and some of this
some of these bricks will be from adults
you trusted and loved
that should have known better it's never
okay to abuse a kid
it's never okay to abuse a spouse some
of you
as you're going through the bricks in
your backpack as you're being specific
and honest about them
have to look at the person you're with
right now and realize
this is sick and ill
and dangerous and i gotta get out some
of you will look at the bricks in your
backpack and say
my mom still talks to me that way and
now she's talking to her grandkids my
children that way
enough going through these things these
bricks in your backpack being specific
and honest is hard
okay so number three once you've written
them down you've got to get other people
in your life to look at them with you
that's why i'm always telling folks you
cannot be a whole person without
relationships period
so if you've got one or two people that
you trust in your life sitting down with
them one day
and just saying hey i need to go through
some of this stuff with you i need to
tell you guys some stuff that happened
to me as a kid
am i crazy am i feeling and processing
this in a healthy
way and they may say dude that's not i
you may feel that way i wouldn't wrap my
head as that as trauma
or they more than likely look at you and
say dude that's a really big deal
and you're minimizing this is a huge
thing some of you don't have many of us
don't have people like that
in your life so you got to go see a
professional
you got to go see a professional to help
you look at those bricks sometimes
they'll hold them for you and hold them
up and let you see them
and then you put them back down right
but you got to get with other people
and then here's the magic you got to set
them down what does this look like
looks like you've got to practice
controlling your thoughts those
intrusive thoughts that come in
you got to notice how your body feels
whenever you think of that
that thing that happened when you're a
kid does your heart start racing do you
immediately reach for
a cigarette you immediately reach for a
drink you immediately want to get up and
go grab something to eat
you immediately go on and go work out
what is the thing right you gotta
notice how these things feel in your
body when old demons come calling you
got our old memories you gotta literally
say out loud no no right so
i still have in my head some terrible
things i said to people when i was in
middle school
i was a jerk man and some things i said
yeah especially in middle school and for
some
i i didn't recognize this until years
ago until a few years ago
i'm in my 30s and i think oh i'm still
carrying around that i'm a bad guy
i'm a bad human being not that i was an
idiot of a 13 year old
i'm a bad human right and so when those
memories pop in my head sometimes i'll
be getting ready for a a big talk on
stage
and that voice will go who are you man
remember
and i'll say nope nope not gonna do it
i'm not gonna give an audience to that
voice because that's just
that's just old john trying to come in
and self-sabotage what we're doing here
man
i may need to go for a walk in a.a right
you need to call your sponsor you may
need to call your friends et cetera
you got to practice not reacting right
and that's the last thing you got to
develop a new identity
who are you going to be now who are you
going to be now how are you going to
navigate the world not as a jerk or an
idiot or a cheater or an abuse survivor
or someone who did something you cheated
on their spouse but
who are you gonna be now right i think
it was carl young or adler
one of them said i always thought if i
could remove depression and anxiety from
my client
they would be well but they weren't they
were hollow
because anxiety depression played a role
i have to give them new skills i've got
to teach them who they're going to be
now so you've got to get with folks in
your life whether that's a counselor or
friends
family community that's going to help
you develop your new identities moving
forward not after the
best i mean not after the worst things
that happened to you the worst things
you did
but who am i going to become now so
those are my
five tips on how to i hate five tip
things
these are the three tips on that well i
just did it there you go how to put your
bricks
down uh if anyone has any more questions
about that call me with some specific
examples of what's going on in your life
we'll get there
all right let's go to rachel in
manchester new hampshire rachel what's
going on how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
today for sure thank you for calling
so what's going on yeah so my husband
and i have been
married for three years um we have two
little kids
and he has some um some really bad
habits um for lack of a better word that
he
has always had since he was probably a
teenager and things like that that
um weren't weren't really a problem when
we were dating things like that but now
they're really starting to affect his
health and our family and it's been
bringing me a lot of anxiety about what
our future is going to look like if they
they continue so what's going on what
are they um
so i guess the main one is he has really
severe asthma
and he also smokes a lot like a pack a
day kind of
sometimes less but around that and it's
actually he's been admitted to the
hospital twice in the last year for
breathing related issues yikes um for
like three plus days each time
um and things like that it just seems to
be getting worse instead of better
other things related to that too but it
just makes me
worried you know with two little kids
he's only 32 and i'm 25 and i just feel
like
these are things you shouldn't be
dealing with for a long time these kinds
of health health issues
so um if i drill down here is it there's
something more than smoking
um i mean it's it's all kinds of just
unhealthy not
taking care of himself really well
unhealthy eating
unhealthy lots of drinking um not like
in a in a dangerous way or anything but
just just a lot of those types of habits
okay so when when
this is the uh the powerlessness part of
being
married to somebody who doesn't take
care of their body right
um you know that you can't make him eat
well
you know that you can't make him quit
smoking or stop drinking or stop
you know i don't know whatever playing
video games so 2am whatever you
can only deal with you so when you see
these behaviors
what has your strategy been over the
last year or the last two years
how do you approach him with your
concerns
um i've probably tried everything
including the things that don't help at
all like
expressing to him how concerned it makes
me and how i don't like our
our kids learning from those behaviors
and watching him do these things and
a lot of probably guilt which i'm sure
is not the right approach
but um it's hard though right i mean i'm
not here
i'm not going to beat you up of course
man those things are hard and it's
important for him to know how you feel
on it
when you sit him down and say hey listen
i love you and at this current
trajectory you're not going to be with
us very long
and the time you are going to have with
us is going to be less than
because you don't feel good you don't um
you don't feel healthy or whole and when
you don't feel healthier whole you're
short with us you snap at us you end up
in the hospital
fill in the blank here what's his
response to you how does he how does he
how does he respond um he
always makes me feel really heard and
then nothing
changes he says i understand i can see
why you feel that way
you know kind of all those things but
but nothing
or i know i know i need to do something
different but okay
doesn't it doesn't change have you told
them that that you're scared
yes that you're scared you're gonna end
up a single mom
yes i i think he has
he has a lot of things from um before i
knew him like a lot of childhood things
that sure i think
um he probably doesn't really want to
deal with but i'm sure contribute to
some of these choices
of course i do of course so here's the
part you're going to have to wrestle
with
you're probably already there i'll just
ask you is it gotten to a point where
you
believe he's choosing these behaviors
that you know are going to kill him
that he's choosing this over you and
over your kids
um i i don't know if i want to say that
he does it intentionally
no not intentionally but really good
yeah not intentionally but
at the end of the day there's one road
to
being with you guys for a long time and
then there's one road to
a much shorter a much shorter less
healthier life
then yes i mean i think i think he knows
i don't know if he
um really applies it to his life like
yes this is going to shorten my life and
everything but i'm sure
he's heard that from his doctors and for
me and he knows that and
they just don't don't change and um
i know i can't change them i know that's
what every good
counselor will say can i tell you rachel
i like
that's heartbreaking for me and i'm
sorry
i got i wish there was a um like oh
you just need to and you can't
at the end of the day if you've sat down
and looked at me and said i'm scared to
death i'm gonna lose you
and i'm scared to death that our little
our little babies are gonna be without
you
and i'm asking you on behalf of us and
on behalf of yourself
somebody who i love i want you to love
yourself as much as i love you
and he says man i hear you baby and then
he goes outside and smokes
goes outside and has a few more drinks
um
i want you to know i get that's
heartbreaking
i hate that for you i hate that for
every spouse every partner in the
country
whose husband or wife girlfriend or
boyfriend don't love them as much as
they do
right they don't love themselves as much
as their partner does i hate that for
you
the best you can do in this situation is
number one
go see somebody yourself on how to
process this because this doesn't get
better it gets harder okay
there is some hope that he begins to
see you taking care of yourself
and it's not an immediate turnaround but
it becomes
a long slow turn
right you start walking taller you start
doing the things that you can do
which are very limited to take care of
you and your and your kids
the second thing is is you can make some
declarations in your home you're not
going to be drunk in this house
you're not gonna smoke inside this house
and subject the kids to this stuff
right um i'm assuming that he's
otherwise a great human being and he's a
good dad and a good husband is that fair
yeah and he respects any of the
boundaries you set up like i've told
them i don't want the kids to see him
smoking and he always
you know goes outside and around the
corner and away from them and
stuff like that so he tries to respect
those things so he's
man so can i tell you i've got a an
especially big heart for folks with big
hearts who are trapped
you know what i mean who are just
trapped i would love for you to tell him
to give me a shout i'd love to talk to
him
not in a mean or ugly way but just to
say man
i get it and i know and there's healing
if you want to make some major changes
in your life um
until then you're gonna have to decide
what your
breaking point is what your if then
point is
and i'll tell you that you know this but
i'll just repeat it
blaming criticizing um complaining those
things
never solve connection level issues
and we're in the middle of what i would
call it's a they're called diseases of
despair have you heard that term
yeah like we're experiencing that at
at unfathomable
levels particularly in men
who are just they're calling it long
tail suicide right
they are just intentionally not taking
care of themselves over a long period of
time they know what they're doing is
slowly
slowly um taking them out of the ball
game
and they're just not making changes
because it's hard it is hard and i'm
asking every guy
if that's you listening to this go get
the help and care that you need
i want you to hear rachel's voice i want
you to hear a
mom who loves her babies i want you to
hear a wife
who loves her husband and the husband's
a good guy
he just can't get over this idea that
the guy he sees in the mirror is worth
sleeping all night it's worth being able
to run around and play with his kids
without having to bend over and catch
his breath
is worth being healthy and living a long
long healthy life
rachel i don't have a magic thing for
you then you've got to take care of
yourself and you got to make sure you
and your kids are safe
taking care of yourself might be how do
i how long do i keep loving this guy
because i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
pulled underwater too i hope you'll stay
connected to him and love him the best
that you know how
and i hope he will man
be inspired by you be inspired by that
connection and sometimes
somehow someway come to the realization
that he has value it may be man maybe
invite him to couples counseling maybe a
third neutral party will help
have him call my show but this one
this one doesn't always have a happy
ending it just doesn't and i hate that
for you
oh man sorry about that
as we wrap up the show man this is this
is a
what an astute song here man
it's a song that came out when i was a
kid
and um i think it meant more about uh
breakups but i think it applies here
from one of my favorite
80s 90s hair metal bands and the song's
called heartbreak station
and the song goes like this waiting at
the station
tears filling up my eyes sometimes the
pain you hide burns like a fire
and you look out my window and sometimes
it's hard to see that the things you
want in life
come and go so easily
she took the last train out of my heart
she took the last train and now i think
i'll make a brand new start
she took the last train out of my heart
watching the days go by thinking about
the plans we made and the days turn into
years it's funny how they
fade away sometimes i think of those
days sometimes i just hide away waiting
on that 9
20 train waiting on a memory she took
the last train
out of my heart men if you're listening
to this
i know this was about some girl
somewhere in some 80s love song
but guys don't leave the person you love
sitting at a train station
watching you go because you didn't take
care of yourself you didn't look in the
mirror and think you had value you do
find somebody start making some changes
today this is the dr john dolone show